here as he checks back in guarded by  meal two guys who  grew up in the same neighborhood here's  tatum over  conference player of the week jason  tatum third time this season  [Music]  the performance of tatum here in this  third quarter tatum played by  smith looking to draw the foul it did  not mess  went into three celtics right here he's  just  he's feeling it right there head to  smaller who's gonna dominate and dictate  pace in boston right now  kind of junking it up making it ugly  playing slow pace and  putting the ball in tatum's hand  as he's two away from 50 points just a  beautiful step back  three-pointer right there philadelphia  76ers so two  childhood friends jason tatum and  bradley beal  sharing a laugh i think tatum can  certainly enjoy  uh whatever was said but uh jason the  story tonight 50 points  on 14 for 32 perfect at the line  17 for 17 plus eight rebounds and four  assists  beale came on after a slate late start  and finished with